michel onfray vous qu'est ce qui vous
sépare encore de marine le pen
il faudrait qu'elle est un corpus
doctrinal qui soit claire et qui soit
lisible
voilà quelqu'un qui depuis qu'elle fait
de la politique est passée par par tous
les stades c'est à dire que l aele a
pris le l'idéologie de son père clés en
main ensuite elle a pris une idéologie
qui était celle de filippo maintenant il
écrit dans l'opinion que finalement le
rôle europe le marché tout ça c'est
formidable ça fait quand même quelque
chose de signaux et dale moi je vote pas
pour des gens je vote pour des idées
quand mélenchon était contre le traité
de maastricht et colonnes aujourd'hui on
dit qu'il est contre pas estimé que
quelqu'un peut diriger le pays
s'inscrire dans l'histoire de france
quand il n'a pas su ce qu'était la
réalité du monde et comment il a fait
pour ne pas saisir la réalité du monde
donc marine le pen elle est une
héritière
et puis là il est en train de se dire
mais comment puis-je arrivée au pouvoir
qu'est ce que je pourrais bien dire et
qui me conduiraient etc ça n'est pas une
femme de convictions et moi je ne
voterai que pour quelqu'un qui soit
personnes de conviction
[Musique]